Before describing the technical
requirements for virtualization,
let's take a look at
the Two Main Virtualization Models.
The two popular models for
virtualization are called Bare-metal or
Hypervisor-based and Hosted.
They are also often referred to as (type
1) for the Hypervisor-based model and
(type 2) for the Hosted model for
virtualization solutions.
The Bare-metal model is like
what we illustrated before.
A virtual machine monitor or
hypervisor is responsible for
the management of
the physical resources, and
it supports execution of
entire virtual machine.
One issue with this model are devices.
According to the model, the hypervisor
must manage all possible devices, or
stated differently, device manufacturers
now have to provide the device drivers,
not just for the different
operating systems, but also for
the different hypervisors
that are out there.
To illuminate this,
the hypervisor model typically
integrates a special virtual machine.
Like a service VM that runs
a standard operating system and
has full hardware privileges to
access and perform any kind of
hardware manipulation just like if
you were in need of BMV hardware.
It is this privilege VM then that would
run all of the device drivers and
would have control over how
the devices on the platform are used.
The service VM also runs some
other management tasks and
configuration tasks that specifies
exactly how the hypervisor
would share the resources across
the guest VMs, for instance.
This model is adapted by the Xen
virtualization solution,
as, and also by the VMware's hypervisor,
the ESX hypervisor.
Regarding Xen, both when it comes
to the open source version,
as well as the version that's
supported by Citrix, the Xen server.
The VMs that are run in the virtualized
environment are referred to as domains.
The privileged domain is called dom 0,
and
the guest VMs are referred to as domUs.
Xen is the actual hypervisor and
all of the drivers are running in
the privileged domain, in dom 0.
So the management of all of
the devices has to involve
the execution of the drivers
that are part of dom 0.
Given that VMware and
its hypervisors were first to market,
VMware still owns the largest
percentage of virtualized server cores.
So these server cores
run the ESX hypervisor.
Even this fact, viewers in
a position to actually mandate
from the vendors that they do provide
the drivers for the different devices.
That are going to be
part of the hypervisor.
Now, this is not as bad because this
is really targeting the server.
Part of the market space and
in servers in data centers there not
going to be that many devices or
there are going to be relatively
a fewer devices compared to what
you would see on your laptop or desktops
or in general the client platforms.
To support a third party community
of developers VMware actually also
exports a number of APIs.
So this not just for
the sake of the developers, but
also for users when they want to
configure exactly the kinds of policies
that will be enforced by the hypervisor.
And in the past the ESX architecture
was such that there was
a control core,
a core domain, if you will,
that was based on a regular operating
system, it was based on Linux.
But the right now,
all of the configuration related
tasks are configured via remote APIs.